I'm practicing something and now that
Nick brought his coins here to
demonstrate the whole silver thing I can
show you some yo-yo yo-yo put this here
and slightly oh my gosh shocked myself
what two bolts man sorry what's up hey
get that going on you what you just like
keep it in your shirt I mean I just keep
going with it yesterday this is the real
one yeah all right oh man render like
this has magic trick knees yep all right
yeah I'm the coin you're gonna make it
like disappear something I'm not
watching hands oh [ __ ] dude wait did you
get that
yep there you go I hope you guys enjoyed
that all right a while yeah but that's
like in your pocket did you just take
your coin
[Music]
Hunter Street in the last couple years
has been increasingly populated I walked
out the other day found this big dent
and like in the plastic maybe it was Sam
driving the Traxxas around
that's why you lease ownership is
overrated I disagree with that how does
it make me feel to have my car
Denton yeah makes me feel bad it makes
me feel sad there's so many things to be
happy about in life I mean I just I just
passed a guy on the street and he was
missing a leg could be worse
that a little debt on a car who's that
there's a phone leaning up against the
step to our door which is literally just
sitting there like propped up it's on is
it a lot it's not locked I'm in the
phone right now I like to think I'm a
good person and the person who happens
to uh set the stone there is lucky that
I found it we got to figure out who this
is background the phone it's a girl a
baby is it the baby's phone there's a
page that's just entirely camera apps a
little weird only 52 pictures on his
phone they're all pictures of babies
also I know on Google Maps it tends to
automatically find your home oh and
maybe she's locked in a belongs to Anna
Chavez Jackie I'm called Jackie haha hi
is this Jackie I I found I think one of
your friends phones is her name Anna
that's your mom okay your mom your mom
lost her or left her phone found it on
the ground we should probably try to get
it back to her do you know who can come
and grab it did you work on a hunter
Street by chance yes okay that's right
that's right I found the phone do you
know who she works for
okay cool well I'll just walk over there
and give her phone back no problem thank
you
all right all right cool let's go give
it back it's on another person's phone
in college that fall out of pocket boss
isn't she singing the chair in front of
me and I grabbed it later that evening I
called I think it's a boyfriend she
basically aachen girls go get my phone
you go here you didn't say thanks didn't
like that
somebody left their phone in there of
tatiana yeah sure yeah this is an
amazing song oh okay cool thanks thank
you yeah yeah you can pull it up with a
code maker it's flush so I just went out
to my car I wanted to change my clothes
get my phone and put on a pocket and
like all right that's everything and I
closed up then I realize I don't have my
keys and I just locked him in the trunk
once or twice do you want your windows
to not be broken yes verbally I have a
slim jim
you didn't tell me the windows cracked a
little yen is correct
that's like Weezy I'm assuming yours is
probably where - I mock button yeah yeah
the center yeah yeah let's go back in
and get the tool let's go back in and
get some tools
what is trippin on my part was to break
into my car all of a sudden this is the
easiest thing to fix just get a stick
press the unlock button the windows
mostly open pull pull the door oh sorry
sorry huh just like I couldn't see any
longer so Oh getting the door handle
doesn't work I mean I just tried so one
more time and I can help - mystery boxes
as right now I have no idea who these
people are or what they've sent us so
let's find out
I notice ascent to Sam and I'm not
saying but whatever hi James and Sam on
behalf of our team at brand
Entertainment Network we want to take
one to thank both of you for sharing
your expertise and be a key part of a
first brand integration summit in LA
Oh class right now Sam wants to be here
yeah are you sure
Brandon Entertainment Network is a bill
gates company I look how in today's
YouTube atmosphere you have to like
consciously say no this isn't sponsored
but the thing is is that actually
caramel corn is probably my favorite
type of corn oh well my in chili
chocolate mmm banana foster with dark
room beside popping that corn popping
that color of that corn
oh that's good Mayan chili chocolate and
then review um um sorry it's okay no the
colors are saying oh that's different
no it tastes just like mine chili
chocolate hey Sam hey Sam hey Sam
here we go brennon ready Wow good I'm
really gonna get it yeah [ __ ]
trickshot
just going straight out you're fun right
to one last one last one we're making
about three to one
[Music]
with things like this the easiest thing
to do is to open up the handle on the
door because it unlocks the is so close
to doing it
[Music]
but this is like just a little too short
it's always the case isn't it there's a
broomstick right here oh my god Northup
that's but not working matter Carter a
minute huh no it's a lot ah it's not
that instead of look what okay let go
that care Michael oh oh
alright that was solved I got a teach
you a lesson you never liked yourself on
me yeah you hear that hear that cut that
out
this is private talk
[Music]
I don't know it doesn't want to like
none of my locks will unlock I don't get
it
tried I'll try it open the trunk trunk
popped Wow
so his keys are in the trunk still
locked I am pushing the button your keys
is there a fold-down scissor fold down
seat
we know lead to the back yeah the seats
do fold oh it does lead to the back you
have to Coral through the receipt yeah
these don't let that dude that sucks
you can't pull down your seat hold down
the button I don't know where anything
is my life's a mess the other night I
was just driving down Hunter Street all
of a sudden all the locks on my car
we're going krrish cuz Coosh Coosh Coosh
Coosh
opening and closing for no reason I was
freaking out or my car was possessed